la grande classique du paris versailles
a fait le plein une nouvelle fois cette
année la course à pied de 16 km entre la
tour eiffel le château de versailles a
attiré plus de 25000 personnes pour sa
39e édition c'est sur une aussi belle
cause mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas eu
beaucoup de chance à cause de la pluie
on est parti sous soleil arrivée sous la
pluie mais c'est toujours une belle
course à faire arriver dans cette belle
ville de versailles le parcours est
magnifique il ya du monde surtout
parcours qui nous encouragent qui nous
encourageons passe dans les bois c'est
vraiment top la principale difficulté de
ce circuit se situer sur la côte des
gars de meudon un secteur avec 170 m de
dénivelé on le savait au 5e kilomètre à
la cote des gardes qui dure 2 kilomètres
mais après c'est quand même et moi une
succession de montées descentes donc ça
casse bien les gens mais sur la
princesse est dur de ces dures d'activer
les cinq premiers kilomètres très facile
comme d'habitude la cause la beauté de
la garde qui complexe à gérer faut
savoir relancer derrière et après c'est
que du plaisir faut savoir le kenyan
stéphane ou gary a remporté l'épreuve en
49 minutes et 59 secondes il a devancé
le burundais abraham niyonkuru de 17
secondes chez les féminines
l'éthiopienne moldus a terminé en 55
minutes et 19 secondes
[Musique]